we would expect this is the last trench
but obviously we can always reconsider
that but this is a lot of money going
out that's over six hundred billion
dollars putting into small businesses
which are the backbone of the economy
50% of the private payrolls so Steven
Minuten from last evening the house
expected a vote tomorrow on a nearly
TRAF trillion dollar aid package the
Senate passed yesterday here is Nancy
Pelosi's reaction on this a bit earlier
today Mitch McConnell likes to say we
delayed the bill no he delayed the bill
among two weeks ago he came to the floor
and said this is all we're doing just
the 250 and that Democrats were reunited
House and Senate the Senate Democrats
went to the floor and said no no to that
we have a better idea
so that was him earlier today and with
me now Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell to respond in kind
senator good afternoon to you and a very
empty Washington DC thank you for your
time yeah I'm glad to be with you I
think the public's kind of bored with
this back and forth partisan
back-and-forth
mm-hmm I mean the facts are that we
tried to get relief for this small
business package 12 days ago it was in
fact delayed Democratic maneuvers but
look yeah I don't think the public's
against is not what they are into doing
what did we do yesterday we put three
hundred and ten billion dollars under
replenish the program for small
businesses which ran out of money 12
days ago and we also added 75 billion
dollars for hospitals we know they're
struggling and probably even more
important than 25 billion dollars for
testing we've really developed kind of a
Manhattan Project approach to testing
because we know that even when the
governor's began to open up the economy
is in my view they should begin to do
and when hospitals are allowed once
again to do elective surgery which is
the only place they make any money we
can begin to get out of this malaise by
bringing the economy back to life you
know I'm going to ask about that in a
moment but that's what she said that she
made the bill
better because of the testing and the
billions that are now available for
hospitals that was the point she was
making in that okay well we'll continue
it further
she's claiming that only they were
interested in hospitals and testing
that's not correct they were we were all
interested in that none of that was in
contention what they really wanted to do
was to pass legislation to send money
down to states and local governments and
what I said was we're not going to do
that we're gonna wait we're gonna take a
pause we're gonna we're going to assess
the future potential damage to the
country by adding 2.7 trillion dollars
to the national debt and the next time
we consider a shell sa phase for me
after all the members of Senator Bakk
which earliest will be made forth do you
uh do you still have that okay go ahead
we're not we're not interested in
revenue replacement for state
governments we're interested in trying
to help them but anytime we related to
the coronavirus we're not interested and
solving their pension problems or all
these other things that they would like
for us to finance on that point Mayor
Bill DeBlasio here in New York on this
program a week ago said he wants
Washington to provide seven point four
billion dollars to help New York that's
just the city now are you saying today
that will not happen from Washington no
what I'm saying is we're going to take a
pause here we're gonna wait at least
until May the fourth which we is the
time we're gonna have everybody back in
the Senate and clearly way before we
provide assistance to states and local
governments who would love for us to
borrow money from future generations to
make sure that they have no revenue
losses before we make that decision
we're gonna weigh the impact of what
we've already added to the national debt
and make certain that if we provide
additional assistance for state and
local governments it's only for Coronas
related coronavirus related matters
we're not interested in solving their
pension problems for them they're not
interested in rescuing them from
decisions they've made in the past we're
not going to let them take advantage of
this pandemic to solve a lot of problems
that they created for themselves with
bad decisions in the past I know we're
pressed for time here let me just try
and squeeze in a few more may fourth
there's about 12 days away do you see
the Senate coming back to work on the
4th of May no that's our plan yes okay
with regard to the pause you mentioned
there what what do you see or how do you
forecast what could be in the next bill
or the next tranche of hundreds of
billions of dollars well the first thing
is to decide whether there needs to be
another charge I mean the ultimate
solution to this is to get the economy
back up and running I'm encouraging our
governor for example and he's already
doing it to begin to make steps and the
direction of opening up the economy the
solution to the hospital problem is
elective surgery which is the only place
they're making any money that's a state
decision so all of us are going to be
encouraging our states to begin to move
in the direction of getting back to
normal
bearing in mind the advice of doctor
Falchi and dr. Burke's social distancing
is the D stigmatization of wearing a
bass nobody should be embarrassed to
wear a mask and let's ease back in on
the problem by getting growth back in
our economy just one last thing I know
we're running out of time here but when
you try and characterize how things are
working so far well what word would you
use to describe that you talk to
different entities across America you
get different reactions how would you
describe what the efforts have done so
far out of capital well I think we've
tried to deal with a disaster but
anytime you throw a 2.7 trillion dollars
out over a short period of time they're
going to be mistakes made and so the
next time we act we'll have the benefit
of experience you know what did we
already do how much other could be done
better or do we do it at all
bearing in mind the impact on the future
of the country with mounting this kind
of debt all of that needs to be can
centered in a more thoughtful more
measured way before we start acting
again sir thank you for your time Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell in an MT
Washington DC thank you sir